they all have high probability roll
numbers so that's what you're really
going for
how would I capture one of these
captures this little Pokemon dude how do
I take it over the [ __ ] how does it
become how do I colonize one of these
you just [ __ ] so you were gonna get
uh great question is there a disease
card so here's what what uh
turn
foreign
it must be red
you know it's your turn to roll yeah
roll so we're looking for the highest
number possibly
this is really
oh can I do this
eight
eight again you suck again
so we're tied I don't know if you
understand right now oh I can love it I
mean oh [ __ ] you good job man
eight so you go first
so put down a settlement and a road on a
spot with as many dots as possible so
this has five plus three plus three this
is eleven
it's a pretty good spot and it's diverse
too this spot is 9 12. this spot's a
good spot a spot's a good spot
and then put a road pointing somewhere
good they're not too good so this is how
you collect [ __ ] okay so you're gonna
want to get this is going to build your
city you're gonna get a settlement first
you're gonna get two the whole point of
this game is three points where you get
10 victory points is either by one
building a settlement or pulling a
victory point out of the development
card pool or building a city a city is
going to give you two victory points so
that's how you can upgrade your
settlement into a city in which you need
two or three ore and two hay
and then
how do I make a city okay
just you just have to play it all right
you'll see yeah it will soon you'll see
here
my next are we going I'm next that's my
turn
calculating
oh this is gonna play some stupid [ __ ]
right now
does he have a name
that's the thief uh the robber the
rapist
it's a murderer oh so he's the one with
the smallpox he's the go-getter of this
community he's out here doing stuff
those have nice triceps son of a [ __ ]
you wouldn't say that Teresa wouldn't
you
all right here we go oh [ __ ] we're
playing the fourth we're playing the six
player board yeah it's a big ass board
dude let's play the let's start over
you can [ __ ] do this dude are you
[ __ ] me right now you want to play
this giant ass board
I mean at this point well it's fun now
it's too late now it's all mixed up
whatever we're gonna go back to Fourth
it's good to be here this uh no it gives
me time to tell you how [ __ ] lame the
Yankees are
the Yankees are the worst franchise in
any sport history okay they they use
their players like they [ __ ] Sprint
out money that's all they do and they
can't [ __ ] beat the asteroids they
just can't they can't do it it's been
four [ __ ] playoff series in a row
where they've played us 15 17 19 not 22.
weren't the industries cheating they
were but so is everybody else well they
got caught for cheating right well it's
because of this [ __ ] snitch named
Mike Friars is what happens
snitch name or whatever snitch [ __ ]
[ __ ] dude he also has the
stupidest mustache ever check out this
mustache look at this dumb [ __ ]
mustache it's just funny Mike Friars
yeah look at this there's no First Art
uh here my look at this [ __ ] stupid
[ __ ] mustache she has he looks like
such a [ __ ] idiot because he is
so what do you think about Kanye
oh so cool
he's definitely like too too successful
for his own good I think he should play
for the Yankees he reminds me of this
young creative man
um from back in the 30s and 40s I
believe his name was
very artistic as well one of the optimal
creatives
[Laughter]
he's so arrogant whenever he's getting
interviewed he's like you're
interrupting me
means you're interrupting me look at
this mustache Hans oh wow
[Laughter]
anyways who's 15 and four
Mike fires in 2019 went 15-4 with the
390 right he also is super [ __ ] lame
he did a good baseball boys
that is established that he is super
lame he also threw a no hitter he did he
did with the wasn't that with the Astros
or was that with the A's
should we use Christ so we're making the
arena smaller here yeah
they'll be good for some of the newer
players
anyway point being is the day he's
[ __ ] sucked dude
they are the worst franchise in any
sport history but they have the most
World Series ones they do 19. it's just
like it's such a travesty so if they
don't suck so the fix was in oh what is
this [ __ ] dude no no no
it's called Veranda this is clearly
these weren't shuffled they were
shuffled anyway just because they're
like this doesn't mean they weren't
shuffled none of them are touching each
other is very low I don't trust you Hans
I feel like you had something to do with
these multiple uh sheep touching at the
end here
that's just how the board is sometimes
oh yeah that's a [ __ ] lie this is
just like how the Yankees got to the
divisions more like how the Astros won
the whole series well everybody was
cheating Hans do your research well
where's the evidence for your claim
um uh there's a ton of evidence still in
the trash the Yankees were cheating that
year too and so we're uh the Boston Red
song
yeah yeah the bra strappers
will you [ __ ] think Boston people
thought correctly huh
led the league in Wild pitches in 2016
the 17th he also led the lead in uh
getting his butt rammed
what a [ __ ] idiot dude I hate that
guy
um no but my Friars isn't as bad as the
Yankees the entire organizations you
know he did
oustics for cheating super white what I
also hate about the the Astros cheating
franchise is that uh Jose Altuve got
[ __ ] blamed for pretty much all of it
and it was proven that he didn't cheat
at all like he hated like that the team
was cheating but the trash can yeah he
never accepted any pitches they were
saying that he used the buzzer uh and
the enroll this Chapman uh walk-off run
that he had they were saying they had a
buzzer on his shirt that was gonna tell
him what pitch it was Jose Altuve had
been proven by Blake [ __ ] countless
sources to not ever accept you out for
cheating so he never did he was like one
of the only people on the team that did
that but because he was the face of the
organization he took all of the blame
against
like constantly all the time and he's
five foot [ __ ] three dude he didn't
have Apple watch on the heart he didn't
have the heartbeat sensor yeah you can
go first again Jason they were they were
saying that he had a a [ __ ] vibrator
on his nipples okay yeah a little nipple
tape
like you're doing a marathon
I'm gonna put down a road
to Nowhere what would you guys recommend
the first structure
foreign
productive resource there's really not
much you can do with it
unproductive resource that's what Kanye
calls the Jews
I think he uses terms a little bit more
harshly what exactly did he say I
haven't heard his Ace he said the Jews
are controlling he went way back in time
he said that oh what they mer something
about his ancestors getting murdered by
he says he is Jewish yeah okay yes yes
he is Jewish no he's not he just says he
is well he's insane that's the client
yeah he's definitely a crazy [ __ ] guy
oh yeah that's been established for like
20 years yeah he just uses racism like
whenever he wants to say something he's
like I'm black I got to say the Jews are
stupid and then whenever he doesn't want
to he wants to [ __ ] on black people he's
like they're lazy and they're always
some gangster rap and they're always
have a victim mentality it's like he
uses racism to say whatever the [ __ ] he
wants to say he's just trying to make
unique points instead of saying it's
like it's like a true America
well you know uh there's a he doesn't
Pretty he does a pretty solid job I'd
say sometimes uh I will he was saying
that I heard him say that the white man
has hit the hardest of the in the U.S or
like out of everybody yeah a white man
is that has the hardest Pete Davidson
against the hardest stuff
that [ __ ] was [ __ ] hilarious no it's
Dylan your turn do I get to roll I'll do
I just do what we just did yeah except
don't do what I did
do what they do
okay
no no no do what you want man move life
you know you want as many dots as
possible
all right so I heard a rumor
with the hey you gotta pick a Vertex you
can't just build on that edge you got to
build on a corner
this corner like in the middle like in
like right here on the center point yeah
there you go
yeah corner office
why are you trying to be different man
what is a six-sided man I just heard
from my [ __ ] adults hexagon because
they're [ __ ] everybody
oh that's true it's holy geometry
hexagon that's six right that sounds
right
here you go what holy geometry is and
now you go again
yeah some pretty cool [ __ ] dude it's
like uh what our world and universe
revolves around
we're in uh we're like there's like
something
no no it's like
um the Bible and a lot of other things
are uh for like revolves revolve around
figures and numbers like the number six
six six
is that a sequential angle with a couple
of things it's really interesting [ __ ]
dude
um okay all right I'm gonna go don't
worry I understand you've been hanging
out with evangelicals too much no no no
I just talked the one you're a little
bit of Kanye dude
I thought I didn't see you in jail cool
and he was like you know what the sin of
sloth is the worst sin and that's what
he was telling me and I was just like
dude
um yeah those rapist and murderers and
real go-getters they're really out there
doing work
for the Lord
look at what Gareth did he built the
road to nowhere
you shut the [ __ ] up
that's funny because roads are valuable
I mean he has no brick and he wasted his
first road or his second road going
nowhere it's kind of funny
when do we roll the dice when does that
come into play after Jason Goes all
right Alton are these are these gonna
end up connecting is that ideal to build
it closed here
not always okay you just want the best
resources
but sometimes it's good to connect most
of the times now
not your turn yet
are you gonna cut me off here
you're a fan am I trying to
War
okay your turn
let the games begin
and pick up the second reason second
settlements resources
this over here
so the second settlement you put down
put down pick up the resources from that
did you pick up the second settlement
resources
you pick up wood broke and wheat
are you dick
why the hell did you do that you pick up
wood brick anyway
hide the Hydra resources Jason
like that but
the fan does make it sound like we're at
war in here
sounds like Vietnam
okay Jason now you roll the die
you haven't
eleven
oh
okay can you buy anything
how do I buy something
yeah look at that resource card right
there
no I can't buy [ __ ] do you want to trade
so you can go and say hey I need this do
you want that yeah uh if anyone has wood
I'll give them or
nothing
I reached about ore is our ore's good or
it's good or it's good you don't want to
have your cards out like that though
buddy oh is it it's like hide those
cards yeah
I could track them and then you're gonna
be able to tell you know oh he's got
[ __ ] wood and some hay and [ __ ] so do
you think like if you can be obsessed
with baseball you could be obsessed with
anything like darts you just happen to
choose baseball it's just like a random
sport that we all have into a lot of
counting just get into at the same time
well [ __ ] soccer is the shittiest
sport alive
into that well in terms of success I
don't think it's the shittiest sport oh
yeah it's the most popular sport in the
world but I [ __ ] hate soccer I think
it's the most boring thing ever what's
the least popular sport in the morning
are you baseball is a slapping people in
the face
this was very diverse oh it's incredibly
different everyone picked up wood I
rolled a nine [ __ ] yeah
I'll take care of wood
did you pick up wood
you really think baseball's the second
most popular I think so uh it's either
that or Cricket right or rugby I would
say
like crooked or rugby like diverse like
the whole world likes it
what about like tennis UFC's getting up
there
MMA
citizen golf or
um how many cards do you have Dylan I've
got 34. did you pick up a wood one
Gareth rolled I just picked one up okay
huh there's a pick up another one well
he rolled an eye did you pick up when
you were all the nine
yeah there you go
no it's your turn Dylan all right am I
rolling yeah
foreign
this one's for the Yankees let's go DJ
apparently they sung oh you don't need
to do that
that's what the whole thing is for dude
you just roll it and then you you put it
on the ground and you you untake it Oh I
thought I had to like make a whole thing
about it
we're not barbarians yeah all right all
right you already rolled you rolled you
already rolled rolled in nine okay
and that means wood
wood
we all got wood
and then so now
I'm eligible
so like
to build something let's go very basic
here what do I look at your menu
I'm a sheep you can trade people too
I'd like to build a road please
put it down right here
and then anywhere I want you gotta
connect it with your already existing
settlement or Road
where am I able to go I'm gonna go here
here here other here
we go and then are they done we're on
the road yeah that's I think are we
doing okay are we there yet
look at that another good form oh my God
I don't know some good form
do I also pick up before we got room
yeah do whatever you want which I grab
on them all wood nine whatever I want
I'm catching on okay
uh all right looks like I can I can
build a little road so do you think
Bigfoot's an alien no I Think Jesus is
an alien he's a republican
no I mean I'm being silver grown guys
what is Bigfoot like is he in a a r
Arthur pod or figure out what it is it's
like a a monkey that came back and
Arthur it's like it's a type of monkey I
think an arthropod is like a seashell
possibly possible
um I'm not good but don't build there
it's
I think Bigfoot is do not want to go
down here yeah that does nothing all
right here yeah you should go there
are you done yes the pastor dies
I think Bigfoot is a figment of our
imagination no he's [ __ ] not dude
you're too I think he seems like he'd be
real but he's dead there's thousands of
people that have seen him over
Generations there's thousands of people
Johnny Appleseed what kind of genoves
did you get
I think he's got a [ __ ] fat [ __ ] I
think we're assuming I think that is
Bigfoot's [ __ ] is Giant and it's got
really long hair
tunnel bag
what like a cat dick like a small inside
penis that shoots out and has like
spikes and just like a black hole badge
to another
no I think he's an alien I really do
think he's amazing you heard about the
Skin Walkers and like skinwalk like
Indian traditions or something you can't
hide as long as he has with a huge dick
well it just makes sense what yeah it's
your man you're getting funny you gotta
drag that thing around try to go camping
eight
what are the chances that an alien looks
exactly like us just hairier and bigger
Italian be possible right I feel like
most aliens are gonna be no we all come
from monkeys it could be of a a a monkey
descent what is it called what are the
what's the scientific term for monkey
monkey descent that's what it's called
it could have been like a Wuhan lab I
don't think
it's wrong calm down a little boy
I can't do anything here you go
I think Bigfoot is just like a pop
culture thing it's just with our culture
yeah he definitely played for the
Yankees no it's what it's like it seemed
to be a lot better they wish they had
three why do they care it's so weird
what's going on there dude I I kept it
in the the felt like it's a casino put
it down put it take off the top so yeah
three yeah there we go that's uh Brown
an orange orange no orange you don't
pick up a weave
pick up a brick
wait do I get to build something you get
to pick up the three
look at all the threes on the board
sorry so any one of these uh-huh
so you really pick up if your thing is
touching that number
yeah you haven't heard of the skin
walker though so you got three right
here
um
right here it's like an Indian folk Ward
all right it's an Indian folklore where
it was a shape-shifting like
a demon they called it but there was
there's always a UFO site that comes
with it oh yeah dude I believe don't
grab the dice until he passes um I'd
like to build it he said don't cheat
Jason don't build a road you're the one
the Astros have don't do no what save it
for a settlement can you build a
settlement what are you gonna say
anyways back to the alien card yeah I
definitely think other civilizations
have interacted well they also think
other civilizations were more advanced
why did you put that up well definitely
aliens
but that whole the whole thing about the
Skin Walkers and shits really yeah
[Laughter]
and then
how many cards everyone count your cards
the Washington James 46. how many cards
do you have Dylan I have one two three
four five six seven okay now you get to
put this robber anywhere pick it up on a
valuable spot
that would [ __ ] over your opponents and
they get to steal from one person
talking about him anywhere on anything
no Jason he rolled the seven
so don't you think like conspiratorial
thinking is the product of a disease
society that has no power over
things that actually matter
you still feel from Gareth [ __ ] you boys
oh it's only you can only steal from me
so the robber uh whatever uh
you put this on right it correlates with
whomever is on that yeah steal from him
so now you have to stop explaining it to
him just one yeah
please understand it's all wood goddamn
it Go Fish
but no conspiratorial thinking is one
way of saying thinking of it I think the
reason you're saying that right now is
because of propaganda fetty I think the
thing is propaganda to be suspicious of
conspiratorial thinking or conspiracies
yeah but it's just losing yourself in a
endless cycle of like Bigfoot and [ __ ]
well your economy is falling apart right
by what people want you to do yeah you
can take anything too far I'm just
talking about
we're in October
with spooky season so
this is what matters
but can you buy anything
this guy kind of looks like Bigfoot oh
what I'm trying to say is that [ __ ]
we're we're
with let's see with Society
pick it up pick up a [ __ ] War dude
that's you know Bigfoot over here so
with the conspiratorial thinking it's a
[ __ ] elliptical that society's going
on so like in the 80s and 70s six
[ __ ] so in the 80s and 90s uh
you know we would call people [ __ ]
crazy for uh saying that the government
you know was behind the war on drugs and
that we put [ __ ] crack in the ghettos
in the DC and La areas and that all
turned out to be true and now we have a
[ __ ] Netflix show so how does Bigfoot
have to do with something as important
as cracking the ghettos it's what you
were getting back to like it's all the
safe so now now what does Bigfoot up to
do now the narrative how does that be
well the now the nerd had split because
we're using [ __ ] idiots that are on
the internet and getting more knowledge
in that they've ever had right that's
what CIA is doing it overflooding you
and so now you're [ __ ] set with
people going over why did you fall into
Bigfoot thinking I don't really like
Bigfoot but I've always been into uh
aliens and I think that that makes sense
like that Bigfoot is an alien because
there's a lot of stories of him just
disappearing and then there's a lot of
stories of him
shifting or some [ __ ] into a wolf or
just following into the Shadows like
they were tracking him and they couldn't
see him anymore
so it could be any of these things but
we don't [ __ ] no we have no [ __ ]
clothes you pick up your shape
[ __ ] sheep I just don't find this
stuff interesting I just don't think
it's a good thing to think about
Bigfoot and Aliens yeah aliens are a
good thing and it's not practical
life on a small sale can I build
right now yeah it is practical to think
because look how does that change your
behavior
what aliens built everything it does it
but I think hey we're at a point in
society where people are more accepting
of aliens there's so much more [ __ ]
that's happening at this point in in
cultural terms throughout uh not just
Society but human
just in general like we're all saying oh
this is real the government's
acknowledging it like there's a turn in
in thinking about this yeah but it has
to go in a useful Direction it can't
just be about Bigfoot well we all know
nothing Hans nobody's not sure you just
said we have the most information no but
if if we have a scientist that comes
around tomorrow and says this is
actually correct and now we're all
thinking about this now that's how we
all think so we actually know what we
should do we should change our ideas
based on just be open to everything yeah
but there are certain things that
they're definitely not going to say you
can't build it right there
I mean like there's certain things that
they're definitely not gonna say oh
totally like with the JFK stuff
or like Bigfoot is an alien
or he's gay
[Laughter]
where Bigfoot was trying
Bigfoot was Bigfoot was actually that's
the name for his call it was actually
his coffee that's just some guy with a
big [ __ ] they didn't know
how big was actually Britain six
dude we should trade uh Brittany Greiner
for bigfoot that's how we should get
pretty incredible
if Bigfoot was somewhere human he would
be Russian
how do I get her that's not how to build
roads you need brick and wood to build
it
you shouldn't build a road you should
save up for a settlement
fair enough
but this Road's going down
foreign
we had to say he was in last place what
color would you pick first would you go
Brown
I'd go uh everything's doing well right
now here you've got to settlement so
you're winning okay
you have three points I'm trying to
venture out into the world here like I'm
trying to are you done whatever you want
scary stories though
spook season I've been watching that
show The Watcher the vaccine place oh
it's 3K kind of did stuff about that but
what's your favorite spooky stories
you have to give up
four should have grabbed a card no
what's your favorite scary thought
a scary thought dude yeah like Bigfoot
being an alien oh no no no I think scary
thought would just be like if I was
camping
and then and then I like got abducted by
aliens
that would be [ __ ] crazy but first of
all I never can because that's stupid
and we've evolved as a society
I need to stay outside actually I love
camping that's all I think about doing
from you if you're camping and then you
got abducted by glamping if I was just
glam
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
my spooky story is the Yankees making it
to the World Series
didn't happen so don't worry
I'm not a fan sexy
everyone grabs [ __ ]
did I grab a wood
yeah I can't grab it you're [ __ ]
yourself over dude yeah I try to explain
this dude I put that there
again
is
yeah
baby
so what do you think about uh all two
day
he's the man he's my favorite person
it's the greatest postseason hitter of
all time
it's gonna eventually break the record
[ __ ]
standing up
safe
this could be the greatest postseason
hitter of all time
series put it anywhere you want some are
valuable against your enemies
I really don't want the Phillies to win
just so I don't have to hear about it
from Colin O'Mara yeah that would get
annoying
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] anytime you get a
haircut
do you think that it's like you hit a
team and then you're like oh this is my
team and then it's like you're fighting
between each other but it's just play
fighting and it's getting you prepared
for real war when you're like oh my
friend is a Serbian
now you're making me feel like I now
you're transforming my train of thought
am I rolling no you're still interesting
now I'm going to be thinking now what
would you like
oh yeah but people are tribalistic that
that wouldn't happen with me like the
government I just don't like Oklahoma
you know like what did Oklahoma do to
you uh [ __ ] rape my mother and that's
all shot and murdered my father
was she Native American
stealing from
Jason wow back to back no no no
sorry about that bruh I I love UT
football and I hate oeos
we don't live in Peru dude
nobody has the [ __ ] llama there are
the coolest Master is uh the Santa
Barbara sea slugs in my opinion yeah
that's not bad it's a sick ass mascot
dude the sea slug they got some really
cool short shirts too shorts
the sick ass mascot
what are you saying I say things weird
nine
here what are you doing before this
Gareth why are you a little drunk right
now
um
I was playing video games Dylan
oh and I was writing
what are you doing are you writing about
Bigfoot no
um
just about uh uh religious stuff and
yeah sure
who do you think looks most like Bigfoot
of a [ __ ] uh Patrick Demari he's a
fat piece of [ __ ] hairy [ __ ] no
I'm just kidding fuzzy Fuzzy's hair
Mason maybe Mason everybody
who think about it yeah he's slanky this
ain't this [ __ ] McDonald's
watching this lady was like in her
[ __ ] trailer and Bigfoot apparently
just like came up to her door and like
[ __ ] like
like went at it and she like opened like
she looked at him through the like thing
in her trailer and she was just like hey
Bigfoot what the [ __ ] is up like she
wasn't even phased by it she needed I
was like what the [ __ ] yo what the [ __ ]
was mean to me
I was peeping
he's trying to get in there and get that
sweet child or the sweet children he
jerked off in front of her
she wanted to say no but it was a power
complex yeah
out in my life very good but no no no it
was crazy like this chick just was like
oh yeah Bigfoot's uh
just like it was trying to come into my
house and I went outside and I was like
get out of here
dude this chick has some serious [ __ ]
balls and she was just like yeah my
husband was away all night for his night
shift and he just kept coming back like
throughout the tour at the night shaking
why didn't she take a picture oh she uh
like 2002 or something before cameras
were invented
she lived in a trailer in [ __ ] Nevada
I'm a big fan of a lot of money out
there dude
well she she installed a bunch of
cameras after that [ __ ] and she got yeah
she did it she got him like it's it's
some crazy footage because it looks like
he's just coming out of the Shadow over
by the pool
tonight
no like you just see the show Shadow
just come out of the pool Shadow and it
just runs into the night it's crazy
all of them I'd buy all of them I think
she was just cheating on her husband
[Laughter]
oh my God
the kids were just that was just Bigfoot
that's all it was that's why the kids
were it's just platonic well apparently
it was like there's a part of overlay oh
hell yeah give me some milk
there's reports of uh of it happening
all around this area
in general
we want sheep
he trading yeah I need Rock but we
I'll give you a wheat yeah
so say that
say it real good
okay so um
what's what's the big the big boy do
over there for you your mom
the router
yeah this right here it doubles up
seven oh [ __ ] God
[Laughter]
it takes him a while it's like oh yeah I
get to roll oh [ __ ] I lose half my cards
[ __ ] you Hans I didn't like that at all
one two three four
okay
I had plans for that oh you just give it
away yeah
six yeah you can trade four cards of any
one resource from any one card of any
resource so if you have four wood like
at any time yeah I don't know right when
it's your turn organize
immediately
all right here we go so that was a big
loss for you no I actually wasn't I had
a bunch of [ __ ] I didn't need
how the hell are you building a city
right now because I had three stone and
two hey why don't you [ __ ] move the
guy
oh [ __ ] I should do that and I can steal
a card whatever man
oh it's not coming for you
let's see
thank you
so do you think that uh
do you think that the uh the Austin
comedy competition was a fun thing which
one
Jesus that's right
the one where
um
good I wish I would have known man it
was a good vibe it's good it wasn't
eligible Whatever Gets people to come
out and then they can see local comedy I
think I think condos I was eligible to
participate I don't like the idea of
them but they get people out it's a good
format people understand the hard part
is
like the problem with like the funniest
person
they also just specifically chose like
oh like the the Austin Comics
like they didn't uh so I wrote a six
you don't get that
the guy that won the fpia was something
yeah for the old scene from the old
scene right he's really funny he is
really funny but Casey rocket won the I
know and that makes sense
like he's just incredible Casey's the
[ __ ] yeah yeah he's pure comedy he's
literally I remember when I saw him for
the first time I was like yeah everybody
remembers Casey the first time they saw
him and then also he's like one of those
guys you can't just say oh like he could
never steal a Casey rocket
bites all right guys but there's like a
lot of that going on I just seemed like
a wild dog in the back like he is it
that made sense to me but that also is
just like him
[Music]
is made for comedy like he is perfect
for it and he shouldn't be doing
anything else yeah I agree you get four
cards well I just put it down I could
see him being a character or some [ __ ]
you know like a character actor really
well in the future like he could be like
a jack black guy like he's a very good
opportunity
[ __ ] you steal from haunts
I'm the one stealing yeah
this is the kind of people that believe
in Bigfoot yeah
what's going on
[Laughter]
I don't sound like that all right who
has wheat
[ __ ] [ __ ] you dude must have been
Bigfoot
you know Bigfoot's [ __ ] real yeah
weakness
you think he's an angel yeah he's an
alien from where
[ __ ] Delta nine baby
[Laughter]
I am I'm in the OG Universe what did you
know about OG Saturn 10. uh we get some
oh sweet
oh that's my bird call
oh man I need another beer
um
I don't really can't do anything so here
you go
I need some Delta and Iron Man
oh yeah whatever the legal substances in
Texas
another one
anybody go to any concerts
anytime recently do anything cool
and awesome anybody got an ACL that
wasn't cool though that [ __ ] sucked wait
don't do it or anything wind up with
[ __ ] dude it was bad what are you
talking about you hate them
yeah no the biggest fan no
absolutely not go look at like uh 2
000 uh uh 13's lineup
or 11.
um look up I can the 2011 lineup date
one day is essentially the whole the
whole was in the whole ACL last year
so look at the Friday lineup for 2011
ACL I rolled a six oh you guys can't do
that anything this is it
LMFAO with 2011
who was on it were you there I've been
uh almost every single one since 2009
there's only a couple that I've missed
do you buy tickets no usually I had uh
like Fair University or friends whenever
I was a kid they'd give them to me
because I you know I was a child must be
nice to be white oh yeah way to bring in
the race into the conversation wait
you're not white no I'm not
I don't believe in color
um
[Laughter]
well let's see hold on hold on
oh
I'll roll first before I get into this
nine uh we got uh give me a sec
[ __ ] wood
all right I'm running low on cards here
what happens when I uh
cement is it it's a cuckoo
it's a doo-doo
I'm not done yet hold on all right you
gotta roll a little more Jesus Christ
calm down
you couldn't
if you were man enough put your uh oh
you're blue right yeah you're green
I'm gonna just get two brick
use that and then I'm gonna do my turn
foreign
anyway
acl's lineup in 2009 or 2011.
the Friday lineup itself
what a song in the background yeah it
was just not funny for me it's aliens
yeah 10.
or Bigfoot Bigfoot is an alien piece
10
again
and again
uh do I get to no
the Skrillex was popular back then who
else was oh yeah no Skrillex was on
Friday's lineup as you said that I read
Skrillex uh
yeah so Friday just Friday was
Muse uh Skrillex which was Peak Skrillex
I have Bright Eyes The Kills
um
white wise uh and then
Young the Giant started the day
I'm building a [ __ ] road
his Skrillex close it out no he wasn't
even the closer
Saturday was oh wait what is this
this is not 2011. this is Lollapalooza
this is an ACL dude
fire
thing I don't remember actually
what did you pick up
did you pick up Miley Cyrus yeah
okay
here did you already pick up
nine
nine
ah here we go
so fry a 2011.
why they click on 2009. 2011. Kanye West
was the headliner for Saturday Cold Play
was Friday Nas
um played the same day as Kanye West a
bright eyes Santa gold Pretty Lights was
there I remember seeing them really well
big boy also played nothing well
I haven't seen him whale just like I saw
Bigfoot rat blue eyes he was Sunday
it was an incredible light up in general
if uh if you just look at it it's it's
stupid in comparison to now and it's
essentially like
three of the people that oh that was
just one day Pearl Jam was Sunday
um the Toadies The B-52s the Arctic
Monkeys I saw all these people on the
same day
huh
he's an alien they're all [ __ ] aliens
dude
well it's not an alien eight uh I don't
[ __ ] know anymore man
I just know that the aliens are exists
you ever notice how many squirrels there
are everywhere
everywhere there's not that many here
compared to
see in South America yeah because you
know that they're everywhere
yeah I guess every college campus is
just like squirrel-centric it's
pronouncing girls yeah
okay done Am I Wrong
squirrels are everywhere there should be
a lot more Wildlife but we murdered them
all
but beavers are coming back to Texas
shout out to Beavers what's bringing
them back uh people are conserving the
environment and trying to propagate
Beaver of Life eight
what's so that's making them come back
or are they just [ __ ] more it's been
like a hundred years no they just
migrated up to like where they used to
be
and Bowie killed all of them so and we
destroyed their habitat by damming up
the river well beavers were also worth
like gold like their pelts back in the
day or like [ __ ] go it was
essentially going to be like oh
yeah dude
killed the [ __ ] out of them
well you know in uh London they have the
River Thames
and they didn't jam it up they just let
it flow because that's what rivers do
best if you Dam up a river you [ __ ]
destroy it
you've destroyed the the you know
like and then if you want to get rid of
the dam then you're going to destroy all
the cities that are right by the river
which is all cities by the river yeah
you know the one thing the English is
really taking care of the environment
primary it's like the English
Countryside we went the English
Countryside part of the Industrial
Revolution the chimney sweeps the baby
challenge
yeah even the dumbass British didn't Dam
up their beautiful River for no reason I
love George Carlin's bit on uh like
seeing America for the first time like
his his whole Riff on that it's like one
of my favorites all the time it's like
you ever think like Lewis and Clark were
looking out and buying like the
beautiful landscape of America just some
giant Hill and they're like you know
what [ __ ] all those trees let's put a
[ __ ] shopping mall right there
that's that's what this beautiful
landscape and they built the domain
right after that yeah let's get together
let's get some rich friends
five what the [ __ ] dude
all right oh he's got the diamond
formation guys watch out
I see I see how it popped up does
anybody want to trade for some uh hey
yeah I'd like some no idea
did you build this road what when did
you build this road
you can't build it anywhere here or here
or here or here this is where at least
nowhere okay no because it's too close
to your settlement how the [ __ ] did you
get seven already points what the hell
I'm not pretty to these rules
Hans what your scorecard yeah three
seven yeah it's kind of funny that you
have three and you know anybody might be
doing this whole time that's one more
than you you spent all this time getting
one point what does this mean so if I go
here you get two
you get to trade in two weeks for anyone
of anything but you don't have any Wheat
so if I go here I can trade through
anything yeah one anything okay
[ __ ] I get it
now
don't [ __ ] take it away I didn't know
if you want or not easy
there you go big money
10 it's 11.
I have
yeah
what am I eligible for
nothing
you can suck my dick
can I trade that or something okay
family
can I trade an hour that way you have to
build a settlement on that build a
settlement right
wow that was loud Dylan I'll blow the
Earth
let's get all the card
let's hope I don't roll the seven six
okay
oh
wow
Jesus Christ sorry Jason
[Laughter]
oh yeah
he's circling us
oh all right
dude [ __ ] you Hans what the [ __ ] is
going on right now are you cheating
what's going on how do you have so much
check the tapes [ __ ] you never [ __ ]
beat me by this many points dude this is
nuts
11 points I went oh my god dude are you
[ __ ] kidding me
who came in second third how did that
even happen right now we have to play
again I can't even make it last that is
well worth that
you've been practicing Hans
you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] what the hell
is that dude
I looked down and you had won the game
that's stupid I destroyed your ass I was
[ __ ] [ __ ] that's [ __ ]
I didn't even have to use
so uh Windows is there a second place
ten yeah
I can't hear myself can you hear Dylan
when he talks yeah
hello
I can hear you can always hear the
internet that's not an issue you can't
hit this being can you hear it yeah I
can hear the drizzle okay
we can hear you peeing
I'm not peeing dude it's Bigfoot oh we
can hear something
[Laughter]
you can hear you giggling screaming on
the screen
what are these
development
yeah no
well you didn't have any Wheat anyways
wheat is one of the more important yeah
I realized that
so just compiling a lot of wood [ __ ] you
Hans we're playing again dude sorry I
beat you so that was ridiculous man you
only got three points I know I don't
know what happened I looked down and
then the game was over Gareth and Dylan
are tired that was embarrassing
I'll tell you what
there you were
so what do you think about uh
politics a very big question
well you have any thoughts
I read I'm not very
political myself what do you think like
everyone is doing wrong
I think people are attaching themselves
to exterior identities rather than
discovering themselves
I think that's the main issue
so what is an example of that
well liberalism conservatism
ideologies
so you don't think that we should have
ideologies we should just solve it I
don't think that they shouldn't exist
but I don't think that they should
substitute for your personal life don't
you think that we should have better
ideologies instead of no ideology we
should always work for better
yeah but you don't want to get to the
point where the ideology is doing the
thinking for you so it's like if you
take people who are on the far left and
the far right and you're like very
ideological possessed they all sound the
same right right so maybe it's you but
they're all the same I don't think they
are saying the same thing I think one
side is the opposite of that no no I'm
not I'm not saying that the left and the
right are saying the same thing I'm
saying I'm saying like people who are
say very like ideological ideology
ideologically possessed on the left yeah
all of those people sound the same and
they say all the same talking points and
making all the same whatever and then
well it don't you think like that's the
same thing about facts like oh like this
guy knows a lot of facts they all sound
the same because they're all the same
one plus one equals two yeah
well there's only one right way to do
things
like that's not true well in terms of
SimCity if you're trying to make a
proper City like you don't want to have
the sewage right next to the playground
yeah but there's multiple ways that you
cannot have the situation next to the
playground right that's saying that fact
is the same that everyone's going to say
that so just because like they yeah
they're talking about facts but if
they're adamant about something doesn't
mean I'm talking about a compilation a
compilation of ideas
that all correlate yeah so there's like
a certain way of thinking about things
that is going to produce the correct
results more than another
way of thinking about things
in some scenarios
so what do you think about abortion gay
marriage and marijuana
I just toss it a lot
I feel like again damn it it's a fun
weekend
games
what do you think about politics that's
like
a very vague question
but I mean I think that's an ideology
too to be like don't do anything to the
extremes just be in the middle at all
times well I don't think I don't think
everything should be
um what's the word
[ __ ] it's escaping me
moderation
yeah you should do abortion moderation
for sure you should moderate it yeah gay
marriage you should just do as much as
you want
who came in second you and Gareth tied
for second with three boys
okay it was a it was a SmackDown
and then so what was I building towards
here am I going this way
yeah I guess so
you should have been building towards
this this would be nice
wait yes
I mean it's the middle was kind of
[ __ ] green should have been building
towards here
you should have built right here
and then go right there but the weed is
really important you didn't have any
Wheat
which is the most important element Rock
um so do you get the game now yeah yeah
I'm sure I'm trying to understand the
strategy behind it I don't get it it's a
lot of counting and I'm cool dude the
zero lead strategy is not a good one
that's that was the best strategy last
game this guy that plays Katan who has
YouTube videos says no wheat equals
defeat yeah it makes sense
it's a crucial element it's the only one
that's involved in settlement City and
development cards so yeah that's true
solid prerequisite there for Success so
each one of our cards are different
requirements
you get something
shut up losers
foreign
club and it's like okay you get this
Open Mic they play on a showcase and
there's like a definitive way to step up
you know and here I feel like it's a lot
of like different people like at the
creek it's like a different person runs
the show each day of the week you know
so it's like you have to get to know all
these different people and you're doing
a challenge to navigate when you're
at a certain beginning level I guess
yeah it's good to have a central
organized yeah yeah something that's
like okay like I know if I do this and I
do well that I will be given another
opportunity that will potentially give
me more opportunities
for that but but there's not like as I
would say a specific club that is like
granting that ladder that you can show
Cap City is a Headliners Club it's for
like headline and comments traveling
through to do a weekend and yeah they
don't I mean as far as I don't know
yeah I don't think so they're doing one
it's kind of a secret but Tuesdays now
yeah I don't think they like yeah people
like uh sign up for it and then
oh they don't yeah straight white men
yeah
yeah
are we doing this again
who wants to play again
let's do it
was running back
that was such a bad game what are you
brown again
except the board too
units at the numbers
all right just take them off
I like how you pulled out the Zenith and
maybe or there on you know there's a
great presidential candidate every year
uh Ralph Nader
another president Xenon
got all of the 21st Century
is he still alive we're all NATO yeah
I'm not sure he invented the seat belt
or I was a leader invented the seatbelt
oh I think he's at ACL this year I think
that was because
even over him on Ali G show he's like
[ __ ] his own cows are farting a lot
there they're putting pretty similar to
CO2 maybe we should find a way to
harness cow farts
in my mouth right or alternator was like
they haven't found a way to put a box
over a cow's [ __ ]
he hasn't been found dead yet with two
gunshot wounds in the back of his head
and it's been a little suicide totally
not you know Ralph Nader's still around
yeah he's 88 years old member of the
Green Party
oh my God
that's how you stay alive as a
politician you can just ruin our next
election I think we should finally elect
him
no we should have liked Bernie Sanders
he's run four times to become the
president of the United States
everyone's so [ __ ] cold
yeah out of no one in our generation is
worth a bit of salt because they're
either corrupt and evil or they're
working fast food jobs just numbing
their mind
becoming automatons we don't produce
good people anymore we just produce
robots something that we don't produce
good people I think that our society
outputs robots
and could be just so around us because
they're all educational people are good
like the system we have is bad well
morally it might be good but like
quality wise I don't think they're good
wow
yeah but in China they gotta figure it
out I'll tell you what
what do you mean Chinese people are more
robotic than anyone yeah the super
humans sound they're not [ __ ] waiting
they're doing superhumans now
their culture is
the children we're gonna throw in the
river you ever seen Chinese Bigfoot
his name uh his name
his name is what what
say it again
foreign
I don't need that to be you guys Hans is
a Shifty [ __ ] I don't believe that he
just I got a seven Hans is clearly gonna
win the first roll here he had a 12.
no spoilers all right
four or five
and when I went
wait
shut the [ __ ] up
[Laughter]
anything on the board yeah
okay
go ahead
and shut the [ __ ] up I know what I'm
doing
okay
just give me 20 minutes
I don't know yeah
I spent one thousand dollars on these
lights
dude all of them yeah all of them
combined
even the ones in the ceiling no not the
ones in the ceiling obviously yeah the
ones in the ceiling came with the house
sure he was trying to be nice what
what's going on with your watch how much
do you spit on that dude that's the
gifts that was a gift oh my God you just
big it came with the lights
it's Craigslist man
shut up once
you've got a time here
it's very advantageous to win that first
role in it
sometimes yeah you get the first and
then you got the second boss settlement
and you get to pick the road where do
you want to go
but if you go last you get to pick your
second settlement first do you have to
pick your ideal setup
like here I could get [ __ ] not getting
what I want
Hans loves getting [ __ ] just don't let
it slowly is it just nice to go like
this or do we go by yeah
just to the left yes
who gave it to you man what was the
present a very good friend of mine yeah
it was a joke
Gareth gave it to me
I wish one second off one foot's wrist
I mean what's walking around with the
Rolex on his yeah
oh my gosh
what do you think about that move
what what move
I just [ __ ] dude [ __ ] can't tell you
what to do
don't do that dude that's a bad one why
because there's not enough thoughts it's
not enough
sheep too but I can't go here and I
can't go I can go here yeah yeah but
what's more important is the dots what's
the more higher probability but I I'm so
distraught from all the wheat I didn't
get last time that I gotta be closer to
me somehow
I mean I would go here and here
but that's that's that's what I'm saying
I got it over there right because that's
good
and then you go again
it's like competitive start so far
I feel like a little Boosie believes in
a Bigfoot yeah
you think Kanye West believes in Bigfoot
he has to leave and make fun
yeah
it's his next album
believe in Bigfoot y'all
the Jews are controlling the economy and
Bigfoot's lean them
he's an alien
Pig puts in the aliens is controlling
the economies too which
could you imagine
I put a I put a Bigfoot down here yeah
put it down and roll it around
here
but none of y'all saw Barbarian either
I really want to watch him if you've
heard nothing but good stuff about it if
any of y'all watch The Whitest Kids you
know
yeah oh yeah but yeah so the guy that
made this movie is direct it's his
directorial debut debut
the Barbarian is Barbarian yeah
calmly no it's a horror film it's a
thriller it's about a girl that gets his
Airbnb and it's not what she was
expecting that's literally the thing we
all know that it's a great no it's it's
apparently exactly the opposite of what
you think it's gonna be it's [ __ ] it
looks really cool
um but yeah no uh I can't remember who
it was but the guy that made uh the wife
Miller one of the ones that did that
clearly not the guy that's dead Trevor
uh oh my God Dylan
you got only two resources you got a
bunch of wooden sheets yeah that's not
good man
those are the words
oh [ __ ] it fell apart of the plane guys
oh it's a [ __ ] plan man
it's not a [ __ ] playing until you lose
Little Boots you're on that bad ass yeah
I'll be riding on your [ __ ] like a
[ __ ]
that [ __ ] dog I don't give a
[ __ ]
[Music]
foreign
placement is as [ __ ]
put it down
no [ __ ] you dude I was just [ __ ]
around I didn't see the [ __ ] chicks
that you won by eight points that last
round dude come on man [ __ ] you I don't
know what to tell you man shut the [ __ ]
up I wouldn't have made fun of you if I
knew you were gonna be a [ __ ]
[ __ ] you I didn't see that spouse dude
that's [ __ ]
pick up your last settlement [ __ ] you
man
can't
what's your second settlement uh two
sheep and a wood [ __ ] I should go wood
no you pick up two sheep in the wood
and then your second settlement was this
one two brick and a wood do you want a
Freestyle right now Hans yeah put on a
beat um can you put a beat on the thing
no can you put a beat on the thing
on that contractual thing dude on my
little thing
how do you have a beer
why don't you just bring a bunch when
you were down I [ __ ] forgot Hons
[ __ ] you dude that's such [ __ ]
hey can you grab me woman yeah hey I got
you
all right
royalty free beats
better rapper
today right
you get so many heads
[Music]
yeah can you hear us
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
upon's what you know about pow smell
like p-o-o you're a [ __ ] hoe
you a [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ] on this
[ __ ] hard [ __ ] doing this [ __ ] [ __ ]
like I did your hoe I'm a badass
[ __ ] I'll be blowing bro do it
hard [ __ ] [ __ ] I'll be rock and roll
Scooby-Doo baby I just rocking on that
[ __ ] I be eating all day eating that
[ __ ] [ __ ] I'm a hard [ __ ] hard
with the dick I got Bigfoot dreams I got
Bigfoot dick I'm a [ __ ] baby I'll be
rolling clicks click on your [ __ ] I'll
be doing that [ __ ] on your [ __ ] I'll be
doing this [ __ ] that's a [ __ ]
clip with this [ __ ] [ __ ] what what does
that mean
[ __ ] that's why you're gonna make me a
sandwich
a 10.
10 uh I gotta oh yeah give me that week
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
such a stupid decision
does it go through more Beats
there's one beat that's it
that's all you get
for the rest of time
did you say eight yeah oh look at that
okay all right this isn't good dude ah
[ __ ] I'm sorry building [ __ ] oh my God
two uh I don't think there's a two on
the board
nobody has it though
so we'll re-roll and I got an 11 this
time so oh yeah look at that I get a
break
Who's souping down Ponce Pawns
I'm still [ __ ] dumb I should have
taken that settlement spot
here we go big money
so did you all vote academics anyway
vote here
to vote in the state of Texas
I just haven't you sign it yeah you're
going to I no I'm not going to okay I'm
registered but I'm not gonna vote
yeah I mean it's a pretty tight one
right now baby if you pay attention to
politics and give you [ __ ] about the
economy you should vote duh what it what
would you vote for I wouldn't vote for
uh anybody in particular uh uh I'm not
gonna release those decisions uh to the
public uh but I'll tell you this you
should vote I think what would you what
should what should I vote for
I wouldn't say you should vote for
anything so you should just vote to
goddamn give them freedom
it's not I'm talking about voting for
our Frights and for purposes you can't
shut me up
11. tennis we vote for it
no because it's unconstitutional
yeah
where in the constitution does it say
that Gareth has to talk a lot
the first the first one
the first one says you have the right to
free speech yeah that doesn't mean you
should do it it means you you can do it
but should you I vote no
I think that you want my free speech
I think that's true I like your
restrained speech sometimes
through State Street
that would be cool if you could
administer a restraining order
what the [ __ ] I didn't they didn't it
wasn't that wasn't Gumball
for me you son of a [ __ ]
we'd investment on attendance
oh no it's like a limo do not go hold on
I gotta make something happen
hey
hell no do not go do not go
what do you not go that's against my
third amendment
what is the third amendment
uh the right
to have an attorney president no that's
the Miranda yeah actually not the third
one eleventh third amendment is you
don't have to quarter soldiers in your
home yeah that's what I thought it was
and the fork is to bear arms right
that's the second that's the second yeah
what kind of Texan are you
I don't even know which amendment gives
you the right to shoot Mexicans I'm a
much more
um informed Texan
the fact that I was off on the second
yes
did I win anything on that one no but
you could build something
I can build a road
we all need that right now
no I'm good
yeah this is ridiculous
2012 2011's ACL lineup is just [ __ ]
yeah man Ralph Nader Black Eyed Peas
no not even LMFAO whatever that is
Skrillex Kanye West that year was Miley
Cyrus it was one of the coolest concerts
I've ever been to I slapped Kanye West
hand
it was during his uh uh my darkness what
are you stealing from twisty fantasy
tour
we're all attacking Hans right now
that was really primal
[ __ ]
God damn it I'm such an idiot
oh the whole trajectory is starting to
change
this is like ACL 2011 right 11.
oh
[ __ ]
we want sheep
I think it's sheep you have wheat or
brick no wood I'll give you a break okay
you're not telling who you're voting for
or no I'm not gonna say that what races
are there like do you think are
interesting
uh well I mean I think that the Beto or
are we the governor race in Texas is
really interesting
Robert and he's going against Greg
Abbott who's the incumbent he's been
here for a little while 11 again wow
wheelchair right he's in a wheelchair
he's paralyzed from the neck down he got
hit by a car I think hit by a tree yeah
I think God what an idiot I'm not a
[ __ ] idiot he got a tree falling yeah
he's just a terrible person I hate him
you know he's bad for immigrants he's
bad for abortion he's bad he's bad for
democracy like shuts down vote in places
it's good for trees though the tree
should have finished the job is what
should have happened he should have
[ __ ] what do you think about
expanding I-35 and adding more Lanes to
it uh it sounds awful the thing about it
every time you try to turn half freeway
by the time you finish you already need
more money it's always like yeah it's
just a disaster the thing about the I-35
is that because you build a railroad the
Hillard designed under the Audubon but
he personally designed either
wheelchairs
Taylor did hey whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
why is it your turn what's going on are
you done are you not done yeah I drilled
to 11 right what's going on dude
hey just chill the [ __ ] out everybody
why don't we okay
you want to trade for a wood
I need wood I'll give you a brick or a
stone or a sheet can't say you can do it
can't do it can't go with them can't do
it that sounds racist too I'll take a
ACL Sunday pass that's it
[ __ ] out of here okay can I roll yeah
no uh the the thing about the governor's
race is that in the state of Texas it's
the first year ever or the first
election period ever where uh Hispanics
are the majority uh voters in the same
taxes so I've taken over the state
population so statistically speaking
the last year last uh race that was for
gubernatorial race was really close
between them it they should close the
gap but who knows what the hell is going
to happen and uh I don't like either I
don't get to pick up anything
anyway this is gay you don't you don't
like either oh that's crazy because Beto
is so to the left and Texas is like
oh swing state now it's way more
Democrat than it used to be
yeah but it's been gerrymandered to Hell
on that Florida was two years ago
yesterday
yeah the democracy is under attack I
just don't like the way that the general
incumbent Republican party is leaned
towards so it's just a whole other
Democratic well they just have to play
to their far-right base they just do the
most extreme things possible
right and they're all spineless cowards
for the most sex like Ted Cruz just the
shittiest person alive
[ __ ]
six six
what do I get what do I want six
you're Brown
yeah when uh when can you trade with
somebody what is your return
do you want a sheep
did you pick up your wood dude
oh
do you get how this works I am yeah I do
I am I'm picking it up so if you roll a
six and you have something on a six you
pick that up yeah
sheep you also have to kiss Hans who
wants you maybe later anyway for once
you just give him a kiss what would you
like for a sheep they would wait
okay oh you know would you like you want
a wood I want to Sweet all right that's
it that's how you're willing to
talk about it later
no
what about a rock or a wheat
yeah
that's an interesting
I thought about that for a second
I'll hold off you get a lot of cards
what about a breakfast sheet you get a
lot of cards it says he's gonna win
again we all have to attack him this
only way
how do we do that
I think anytime we get a seven we put it
on that eight or that nine so so we
don't want Hans to have a wheat we don't
want him to have wheat we don't want him
to have stone we don't want him to be
anymore
[Applause]
to need to go to connect his two
civilizations he just asked for a week
so that's 11. what the dick
how many roles I don't [ __ ] know it's
wild
um guys who's got a [ __ ]
forest for me I need some wood
come on
but what would you what would you be
willing to work with for that if you
like if someone were to have wood what
do you need
is how this game works you're looking
for resources I could use a week I don't
have a Wii I have a sheep I have a brick
I have a stone
let me let me pick them up look at that
look at what you need to do this game is
to make victory points okay
I mean I want to say no to a stone a
stone for a wood I'll do it what do you
think
yeah
let's do stuff let's do it okay cool I'm
gonna build a road and let me get the
longest road
so so everyone's looking for wheat
tonight huh
we go we already wait I don't even think
one two three four five
that's fine wow you got a whole that's
what you call the Wallace Road gentlemen
so now I get two victory points for that
but uh it's better than what Hans has
he's gonna he's gonna win eventually so
we need to make sure that doesn't happen
damn well I'm gonna cut off the wheat
Packer over here let's go
come on
come
on
seven that's good that's very good that
means that Han seems to get rid of half
his cards because he's a dumbass really
he needs you need to put this on either
this eight or this nine I think that the
the wheat's a little more valuable let
me go with that yeah wheat seems like
the uh the big prize so far
so I get seven of Pawns as cards
no no no
wherever you want all right what the
[ __ ] did you just say right now you got
seven ones is guards I gave away like
three or four cards dude this is the
second halfway over if you roll a seven
you have to get rid of half of your
cards if you have them seven cards okay
over seven cards he had how many cards
before before we get nine sure
put the robber somewhere you need to put
the rubber on this eight or this nine
and I need to steal a card for level
five all right no put it on the eight or
the nine or don't listen to him
eight or nine yeah
and then I get seven steel cars yeah
that's the way to do it yeah that's it
that's some brick it's a brick Oh
yeah I should keep this to myself right
and then I get Do you want to build
anything
um
yeah I think I think I just told
treehouse
I really thought I got seven cards
another lead for me I don't mean it from
there
so what might suggests do you have the
show
yeah how did you manage to get that show
uh I just asked right she's very nice
about it
and you're like hey there's not enough
straight males producing this show I
think I think Ryder is hilarious that's
funny oh right yeah no absolutely she's
very funny I like I like goofy I met her
I think for the first time like where we
talked on Sunday she did really well but
she said yeah oh it's no it was Friday
it was during her roast
oh yeah but the roast was not good it
was like uh who is she going against is
Craig fergola
oh yeah they both like I think she had
this laundry bit about Craig that was
hilarious he like looked like a walk of
laundry
that was great six but
yeah no it was it was a good time but
she was hilarious I saw her since
a set that was really funny
hold on
no
no you're brown brown six
Brown six
uh trees right wood trees yep there you
go buddy daddy's getting it
come on
come on no no no no
bad
okay that's a fun room it's a little
like
hey let's have hazardly Bill
yeah I think that's kind of what they're
holding on to which room
I made my turn
two now I can roll it up and scold it
yes yes
yeah where are you performing which room
what are you doing
this is
[Music]
gonna get a little five
what does that mean for me so that means
jack [ __ ] for you you're Brown so do you
have anything that says five on any of
the hexagonal tiles that you're around
I'm sorry so this is your Square so you
can get a three you can get a four you
can get an eight
do you think it is six you can get a
nine you can get a three and then this
this means it means nothing to you
because you're not on that one
all right
seven
how many cards you got on let's give her
a half of those [ __ ] two three
four five six seven
I believe you I don't know again count
them again dude I want to see that dude
one two three four five six seven okay
colorful [ __ ] I have one I'm just gonna
keep his hair in no no no no you gotta
move it so move it to the nine no no no
no no to the night yeah there you go how
many cards do you have
seven eight nine ten eleven twelve
nothing
else get rid of four cards yeah
did you
what's up are you are you winning are
you you're doing well all right
no I technically right now how are you
doing I'm winning because I have four
victory points so here's two and I have
the longest road so that's four yeah
okay you're stealing from contest three
okay
now Bigfoot's big
that's an alien mystery but okay
yeah definitely
definitely
but I think that the way we think about
politics is also in the Stream how do
you feel about that you guys
how do you feel about Society in the
tribalism that we have and it's seven
it's not great but it's always been that
way okay
you don't think that our Empire is
slowly crumbling beneath our very feet
oh yeah it's definitely happening
Gareth [ __ ] you I think we're as United
as you've ever been
nice I needed that I hate you
I just think that we're
we're just like we can't conquer any
more countries anymore we gotta like
learn how to like take care of each
other instead of just like destroying
things all the time do you think that uh
the world needs to become United as one
group of people you think the whole
being different countries saying is
hurting us yeah
we gotta be like the United Nations
we need to be globalists think about the
globe the globe
seven
you give me your cards
let's see
I can't do anything so I'm gonna end my
third
that's my am I allowed yeah you're good
before
me yeah yeah man
great times that's like a huge credit
okay
eight no nine
ladies indeed tonight am I granted a
luxury of anything
um
can I can I at least pick a card I mean
yeah
I get a wood okay let's see how your you
look girl yeah
hey uh I don't really know does anyone
need a wood yeah
bro what would you would you like I'll
give you I'll give you a wheat or one
wait for wood what if I had two Woods
what would that
you went for one at the moment yeah
Hans I heard you needed a week I have
weed now
okay
can you buy anything
can I buy it oh
no I know I couldn't at the beginning
why did you trade
because I I had multiple woods and there
was just too much wood I needed don't
give it away you can trade four wooden
for any resource
seven
how many cards do you have
nine eight eight that means you get rid
of four of those cards how many cards do
you have am I required yes you have over
seven cards you need to get rid of four
cards
yeah
oh my God we have to remember we're
bringing that up everything every
[ __ ] nine
the most commonly roll number two
so I think I told you this five times
you're like my mother I gotta tell you
something five or six what are you
thinking about
like what you're like huh all right
let's break this down real quick
you don't have your cards move the
robber
all right give up half my cards that's
fair you is you will move the robber
pick whatever four cards you feel is
best to get rid of and then get rid of
them
a little bit in one card
okay that's how many times you've rolled
the seven and you kind of I don't know
how long he's had eight [ __ ] cars
I can't resist not stealing early cards
no [ __ ] take from Hans you need to
put it on the eight or the nine Hans is
gonna win
it was on the eight so put it on the
nine I'm gonna trust you as a judgment
if God take from haunts I do but it's
just the comedian in me really wants to
see the only card
now you mean that [ __ ] [ __ ] take
for months dude
no I flashed
I
uh
let's see
probably not
oh
all right let's let's see where this
goes seven
are you [ __ ] kidding me
I hate you
how many do that eight yeah
as it goes actually more than two or
three people I have seven I miscountered
you're good you're good you're on the
edge dodged a bullet there
did you ever have uh did you ever get
y'all go do you get gopa for like uh
doordash ever
go puff yeah
don't know what I'm talking about you
know what I'm talking about yeah
why you want to get something
uh no I had their uh six I had
um I can't do anything so it's your turn
I had their Pizza you guys okay it
wasn't bad
straight up a wood
I had their Pizza the other day it
wasn't bad however who's Pizza
go Puffs so they have like their own
Pizza Kitchen it's essentially if you
just want convenient stuff or if you
want a blunt or if you want some beer or
whatever if you want a blunt yeah
sure your doorstep
yeah
CBD or just straight up no no no like
wraps you know okay
all right it's not Texas Isn't that cool
yet
a Stone Bees
so they just bring one up there to the
door they are talking about it being
coming Federal illegal not this voting
session but next yeah which is really
cool they've been saying that for
forever now since like 2023 I bought a
bunch of weed stock
Sundial [ __ ] rip me the [ __ ] off he
can't weed stock yeah I got a bunch of
weed stock I bought it a sundial the
wrong [ __ ] time it's like Dogecoin no
no no it's much more legitimate but it's
uh it was a [ __ ] terrible investment
nonetheless if we stopped going around
man weed stocks [ __ ] really valuable
I mean you could invest also in like
Marlboro or their conglomerates that's a
really good idea yeah because like
Circle K just started releasing
um yeah all right they just started
selling weed and that's what the future
is going to be you know 7-Eleven is
going to have wheat every [ __ ] uh
camel to start in Florida right do you
want to yeah
So Dope yeah well there's a there's a
shop in Austin where you can go and you
can smoke City have you heard about that
no you can go spoke CBD in the [ __ ]
coffee shop Philip was telling you know
the other day oh you go in there yeah
and then you roll up whatever and then
you can smoke it in the shop
and they give you coffee you telling any
super cool Circle K in Florida should
not whatever they're selling you don't
want to inhale it
why any Love Circle K dude they got good
hot dogs they got better hot dogs than
7-Eleven
yeah I've never ever compared the two oh
you never had a gas station hot dog dude
a gas station hot dog uh uh sommelier
I'll tell you what dude I can [ __ ]
sniff out a good guy like eating a hot
dog in a gas station you didn't want
driving away from the gas station with
the hot dog it's just like your mouth
full of hot dogs the best place to get a
hot dog I'll tell you what is outside of
a uh Lowe's or or a Home Depot
Mexican sausage it's not Mexican it's
like it's usually a Jewish guy
at the Lowe's or the Home Depot
uh at the Lowe's Home Depot yeah usually
really good hot dog outside of a Lowe's
or Home Depot the Lowe's inside of a
Home Depot I actually went you know they
were the best fishing the hot dog is
alone what the hell
uh a loan Depot
that was anti-semitic Who Are You Kanye
West him I mean I just look just like
him so
I get it
hold on I'm losing
dead
okay you guys serious conversation topic
yeah
we not rolled an eight or a three at all
something happened
can we is he really uh we're gonna hear
that serious get any of these Stone here
am I lying the wheat I mean I have a
weed I have a wheat
and I'd like to trade that wheat
for something like a brick
or uh an ore Maybe
oh my god I didn't even realize I had a
10 right here too oh my God I'm in India
I don't know how many of them I missed
from that
[Laughter]
um
hahaha
holy [ __ ] I should be winning this game
um what the [ __ ] man
um let me get
come on guys all right
I'd like I like some wood some brick I
gotta hey who's gonna give it to me
how did he have longest road with no
wood
[Laughter]
I got a I got a I got the road building
yeah and you got two more Woods yeah
yeah and you wasted it I did I'm getting
Longest Ride hey this isn't about you
I need that [ __ ] wood I need some
wood who's willing but he's doing it
funny how many you got high roll yet no
dude
even Dylan is sick
you don't want it's a you don't have hay
okay
Barbara
I'm sure
yes though
um
I want some wood
did you
complete all right
that's a good trade
we're good to go
on stop spitting it so much pull it up
don't tell them what to do he's wearing
down my cup
you're putting miles on the cup dude
The Velvet can't handle the company like
a blackjack table okay all right six
we know
Jesus Christ man
every time there's a six-year-old you
grab a wood
yeah I know
please be careful with the cup
this is
eight first eight that's been rolled I
can't believe that two yeah it's wild
holy [ __ ] that was horrible what dude
sounded awful man do you have any CBD
cannabinoids yeah yeah oh yeah dude I
also have some tetrahydral crystals I
can't do that wow
luckily Governor Greg Abbott approves of
your drug choice
a dick
you're in living life why are you just
drawing cards right
you got a nine okay thanks for [ __ ]
showing us I think it was a knife
what what is it what does it say it
looks like that
protect those cars
34. oh my God put back those cards right
now dude I'm Gonna Roll again put those
[ __ ] cards back you cheers dude
I knew it this is the first time with
that virtual copies
[Laughter]
whoa who's did you anybody hear that
right now I think Tron just leveled up
10 I heard
what happened all my cards I want some
shape
uh
he wants brick
what do you rock oh here they are that's
what I need to
what about sheep for Brick I need a
brick
are you overweight anymore
I'll take sheet for two
weeks
don't [ __ ] trade with him he's
winning stop don't listen to him don't
do it what do you think you're important
don't do it dude he's winning it's the
natural way to go Gareth and I are tired
he's a [ __ ] liar he's winning
he's a [ __ ] liar
Shifty look at him oh my God that was my
fault
fish
Berlin with a cup of sauce oh five
that's what your mom said
it's like bricks in her face
I'm sorry that was rough I did not do
another freestyle
I could dude put on a beat dude you want
to do another freestyle
all right okay sleazy dude
relaxed
the relaxing music
[Music]
what a loser he all he did was build the
road now he's just sitting with a big
fat chode
[Music]
[Music]
neck don't give a [ __ ] about the Irish
oh cause they just look like a big fat
dish
what I need is your [ __ ] sucking on my
dick that's what I like are you done
Hans don't give a talk about your
feelings [ __ ] he's a racist
[ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ] and be
flowing that [ __ ] [ __ ] I'll be
doing that katondo [ __ ] resources on
your hoe I'll be doing that [ __ ]
you think it has a wig oh you sucking it
you gag in it oh cause that's how big it
is everyone's licking it everyone wants
to be here
that would [ __ ] ore on this
[ __ ]
doing this [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] you
Hans I wasn't done with my turn [ __ ]
[ __ ] you I'm a [ __ ] mean man
doing that [ __ ] harder like a
[ __ ] trash can cheating on your
[ __ ] like a [ __ ] ass bro
shooting on your [ __ ] like I just did
that ass bro shooting on this [ __ ] like
I just [ __ ] came though I don't give a
[ __ ] I be following on this hard [ __ ]
flow [ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ] you huh you a
bad [ __ ] with the long dicks
wrong
how about that
yeah
Alexa record that was a good beat I like
that baby
thanks guys for saying the lighting is
good I spent a thousand dollars
eight there's your eight here
oh [ __ ] give me a [ __ ] you can trade
four in for any one or anything yeah
cool I'm trading for these breaks in
first um
you would do that wouldn't it
your homes
all right I'm gonna build a city space
[Music]
out here building community
it almost non-existent how dark you are
that's what she said
[ __ ] so how many goddamn Wars have I
missed out on by forgetting I had a 10
on that or as many [ __ ] how many
bricks did you miss out on by not
realizing that you couldn't put your
spot right there instead of going for a
Five Dot spot
that's 11. let's not go back that far in
time
how about your mom giving birth to you
what a giant mistake
more
what an idiot
oh [ __ ] five
foreign
[Music]
have you thought about transitioning
uh no I never once
five yeah weird I'm gonna break
not once how do y'all feel about
transition you want to do Jason do you
wanna you wanna you wanna transition
that's the only reason I'm making any
money
you want to transition
[Laughter]
how do you feel about wanting to
transition just
we know you want to you know we all know
you want you know
I'll tell you what I can transition some
of these bricks of stone
I can transition my bricks and yo my
bricks
not yet
my Stones identify as being in your face
could you imagine instead of kidney
stones you have kidney bricks
oh that's really floating that's really
funny you're so much of an alcoholic
yoga pretty kitty kitty praise
[Laughter]
you're such a fat piece of [ __ ] the
doctor said you didn't have kidney stone
you're a kid either that's a good Bird
that's a really good bird I like that a
lot I'm gonna do that kidney licks
okay we'll say that one to the Rose
battle
[Laughter]
yeah
yeah it was [ __ ] can't grab the
uh it's literally just way too funny
about the phrase kidney bricks
yeah I'm done I was good you can go holy
[ __ ] you have so many cards it's like a
book
me I got a novel over there I got one
two three four five six seven eight
cards three oh three four
of the accumulated sheet
Dylan you want to trade me some wood for
some break
one two three four five all right
[ __ ] all of us
no this is much better yeah you know I
felt that blue and bad at the beginning
of this
so much better is that I think we should
no you want okay I want one
let's do
it so we should we should be like an
ally over here yeah we should move the
other side of the table I don't know why
you could just keep feeding me and then
what I really think
for the rookies
what did I hear
they're allying against us yes
Hans is the enemy five four break
oh you like work
I'm going to trade in a full break for
the stone again with zero five
all right
exquisite
here's your [ __ ] cop
foreign
[Music]
wait what happened to the uh can we do a
uh CBD break
I'm doing sober October but you are uh
why don't we just finish this game up
afterwards yeah
I already explained the water nine
eleven
11.
let's see here
harder
what'd you say about a harder
so what is like the hottest girl that
you've seen
this week
this week yeah oh it's a good question
it's always tough in the city
I mean yeah
you just look at them to the rear view
mirror
I mean sometimes they sit in the front
because there's like three of them or
sometimes like there's one where I pick
up inside the front and I was like
was there someone in the back or does
she just want to be close to you no
they're the girl that was in the back
seat eventually moved to the trunk
is
exactly exactly so did you uh
why did they put the hot one up front
with you that's kind of interesting they
didn't like gather her and like throw
away it should have been that we need to
protect this girl we are actually
voluntarily
she wanted to put herself In Harm's Way
yeah exactly
I had my turn how how is she hot like
what was the attractive thing about her
I've ever seen
beautiful wow that was sexist beautiful
absolutely gorgeous
that's wonderful there's something so
captivating and magnetizing about a
beautiful person that you want to
reproduce with
a good personality
never felt that way about someone no it
just sounded really creepy coming out
here
what you don't analyze your feelings
you're just like oh I have feelings let
me just have them and not think about it
yeah I've been there and I've done that
and then you've thought you're done
thinking yeah
that was just a face
over there
but now I'm good man
all right
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
guys I'm captivated by the romance
if you want if you want a [ __ ] brick
go for it
oh what
no one is talking about you
oh
my God you're all seven right
no no yes
oh [ __ ] yeah how many cards do you have
in you okay enough [ __ ] you man what you
[ __ ] questioning me for you think
I've been sitting here cheating that's
sick cards you're an Astros fan
they didn't [ __ ] win they suck I have
10 cards
ten oh what wait ten
what are you [ __ ] yelling around 40
minutes into a the second game Brown
doesn't know what a victory point is
he got a victory point the first time
[ __ ] you that excuse sweared off 10
minutes Jason has three points
Jason was probably more intelligent than
I am it's not intelligence has nothing
to do
you're more intelligent and like the
muttering under your breath and
plotting
and evil plotting you look like Roswell
ghoul
from Ratatouille
who do people say you look like
yeah
without his makeup on
dude
oh God damn it
[ __ ] yeah
Shadow my pole learning a lot actually
it's on my ass
come on my face you're just getting rid
of stone bro oh yeah
what am I doing the [ __ ] [ __ ]
pull out the one two three four five six
good for you man
it's [ __ ] dick
yeah
that's right
yeah this is my turn
I don't know what the [ __ ] happened in
that last game I just looked down and it
was [ __ ] 11 to 3.
3
oh yeah
laughs
Chocolate Rain you get two sheep
so we'll go others will feel the pain
so what's your favorite internet meme
that has dominated your thought process
oh man uh the the Aaron Rodgers one's
really good I also like the one that's
been going on where it's like the guy
sitting down I forgot which music videos
from but he's like sitting down and he's
writing and then the page
as he's riding into the funniest [ __ ]
ever nice
Dylan don't you have work tomorrow
yeah it doesn't matter
you have to lose
oh I don't work yet I work at home man
me too dude what do you do
that's short that's short for Home Depot
yeah
work from home WF HD I jerk off in front
of a camera for more hours yeah
[Laughter]
jerk off for Craig for four hours
that's a good living
this is the solid way to live
is
it what was the role what was the
numbers
Dylan did you sign up for what I'm
taking you huh ten
two three four five six
okay let me see that
seven
son of it
I will build the settlements
the resources I've collected over time
you would
pay
break and sheep
to reduce the settlement on the sport
City
I will call it the city of Gareth Isle
and then I'm going to get a resource
card
for my dad and I will end my turn
wait it was a lot
that's goddamn right that was a lot that
went a long way I think you ran out of
cards at the end there's that's really
good yeah that ran out of cards that's
exactly what you want and I've taken the
lead as well
while putting a robber on us
is covered in eight
seven minerals a lot I've only been one
world once
for some reason 11's been rolled 10
[ __ ] times in this game tens have
been a lot too teens have been worldwide
as well which is why I've gotten the
winning Advantage here
yeah let's see that spot wasn't too bad
I got a 10 and 11 right there oh for
sure
that wasn't Gareth is winning
I am winning but you still though you
can't trust Hans he's Shifty
I have none if you take for me I have
zero Hans shoes
he's got a victory point where Todd I
don't have a victory he does don't
believe the words
why hasn't been there for so long huh
because I haven't needed to use it yeah
I can tell the lie and you're waiting
against you did you're [ __ ] way
I gotta use it you're gonna eat your
words oh whatever
seven
[ __ ] you
Dylan hmm
what would you like how many cards do
you have try your card I got enough to
party you gotta get rid of that out of
here
God how many cards do you have this is
like a hard time
half of the cards how many are there
just keep playing keep doing your thing
guys I'm watching get rid of half of
your [ __ ] cars hey Real G's moving
silence and violence is over here
because you wouldn't know
yeah exactly right there I have your
cards please
I was just having fun until we get to
start counting my cards out that'd be
kind of thing put it on there yeah he
loves you to organize them he's trying
to give me his cards when you give up
half your cards you put them back on the
pile yeah
I feel bad like I feel like I earned
these and like I did a lot of work to
get them shut the [ __ ] up
dude you can trade four of any card in
for one of any cards yeah just wait till
the wait till we get the no that's half
right there how many cards do you have
now one two okay four five six seven
okay I'm gonna steal one okay which one
just any yeah okay no just fan them out
I guess they're steal one at random he's
acting like he's just playing that's
disgusting why I thought he farted oh it
smells so bad
[Laughter]
actually
[Laughter]
it was gonna be a wild ones
horrification
oh my God
all right all right all right all right
let's all calm down
all right let's calm down here Jesus
calm down
I'm gonna play I'm gonna play this he
has a victory point he has eight [ __ ]
you shut up dude shut up I don't have a
victory Point here [ __ ] liar you're
[ __ ] bullshitter dude
I think I'm finally getting the I'm
getting it
three
I'm seeing Bliss
pick up two sheep
can you buy anything
no I think I'm gonna wait for the next
turn and then we'll go
figure out
free
wow
I'm online development card here you got
a lot of cards too huh I do now I gotta
make fun for that
that's because we were all the seven and
you're supposed to go with Patrick cards
yeah
don't give me a disorder here
what does it say Dylan
uh what does one say this it says night
move Robert okay are you done you know
can you buy anything steel or Resort
s
foreign
11.
he has nine points
don't listen to him
he's a liar and a thief
and he cheats
are he does yes sir next Dylan
I thought about this for a while
and can a roller shut yeah you should
roll first
for a while
Delaware
you'll have a favorite movie horror
movies
um why does everything happen
like
count your cards what
happened
cards get rid of foreign
it's a deflection because they know how
to connect
what's your favorite
the Ring The Ring this is good I like
scream a lot too it's a lot of Comedy
yeah I could be concerned yeah I was a
child it was a super I scared the [ __ ]
on you have you overwatched the thing
before
I don't think so I watched it for the
first time uh are you done Dylan yeah I
just put the four out I'm gonna put the
rubber somewhere put it on Garrett he's
gonna don't do that put it over here huh
let's go from Garrett where am I
entitled to steal a car from here
[Music]
all right yeah okay
if any of y'all seen the thing before
wow
it's an incredible film
uh
nine
the thing is about
um
it's about an alien that landed here
like a hundred thousand years ago and
they were this uh Arctic
um
in uh the middle of our keys
the middle of uh Antarctica for the U.S
government and find this [ __ ]
don't go yet
don't trust him he's got like that
victory points over there no six I have
two
six yep
six
does anybody want to trade for uh a
what would you like
anything I need a uh uh let me get a
wood for a hay don't trade with him he's
a nine points he might win on this turn
yeah
he's a liar I have eight and he's a
[ __ ] he's got seven or eight points
as well he's the one he's nine he's
running he's a liar are you done yeah no
I'm not sure you don't talk for me
nobody talks for Gareth oh okay you go
no I thought your chair right there you
were like
okay
especially after you probably I would
highly recommend watching the thing if
y'all haven't seen it have you seen the
thing before that's totally a cool ass
movie dude
uh I think practical effects films were
so much better than uh CGI horror films
like nowadays of course right that like
so that movie the thing is like the
epitome of practical it's incredible
so well done in general yeah you know
John Carper is anything else Carpenter
yeah
so he made like Jason I think Halloween
he did this movie called the thing as
well he was just he went on a tear in
the 80s and making just incredible films
the thing is like it was so [ __ ] good
um and I watched her the first time I
felt like an idiot I was like how have I
never [ __ ] seen this movie before
it's not a feeling you're familiar with
shut up Hans
[ __ ] idiot no no hit pause
too late dude you're you're [ __ ] up
right now I have three cards they're all
wheat they're all [ __ ] wheat
that's exactly what I eat
yeah son
are you reading the DM channel is that
what somebody said oh I'd like to know
how many points you have
anyway what do you do again what do you
do for work now I [ __ ] play Katana
and I get [ __ ] and I'm all out of
[ __ ] right do you do sales or do you
do computer science work or what do you
do we back up I'm in right engineering
what are you doing yeah can I play this
you engineer
yeah you haven't already move it again
yeah you can you just moved it but you
can move it again if you want
what are you doing yes good he's gonna
win you're [ __ ] up he's got in
Discovery Cards I don't have time
surprises last as long
huh I'm surprised this game has lasted
as long I think you guys are like yeah
can you not hear I was laughing
hysterically what you asked how long
this game was
the first game ended in like 30 minutes
it's always
three
take the [ __ ] sheet
[Music]
right where I want
it
come on pin
oh you [ __ ] nine [ __ ]
oh I'll be scared it has nothing if I
had just hit a 10 right there I'd won
the game
one of you [ __ ] hit it then
Paul's is gonna win the game then this
next turn 11.
[ __ ]
oh why did you pick up brick
was that mean for me nothing
foreign
what are you picking up
just whatever it's uh happening nine
God damn it dude what the [ __ ]
again
okay
put that down
I'll get along this road oh you son of a
[ __ ]
no wait does this not count no
no hey how no you only have five one two
three four wait one two three four five
[ __ ]
this is what I was telling you guys
what were you telling us
so I have
nine points
one two three four five six seven eight
nine
ten
oh my God I'm so [ __ ] mad dude I
[ __ ] hate you so much I [ __ ] knew
it yeah I [ __ ] hate you so much dude
[ __ ] you horns oh that was close I had
fun yeah that was way better than the
last game where I looked down you had
won the game it's [ __ ] up though Hans
wow [ __ ] you man that was a fun one
we're all playing checkers and I'm just
playing guitars
[ __ ] him
well thanks for tuning in